okay we're doing trinity restored but
you turn the rest are in yo the time has
come to decide murderface until a new
building ok I like I've come to a
decision most afraid try to kill both of
you you betray the girl murdered galit
and made us question our future
an agent of nocturnal black everything
I've heard of the stories the 19-year
their allegiance to nocturnal and the
Twilight settled that's why we need to
prepare all right there are better you
want a selfie skip off the mountain the
end of that should bring those photos
and I'll be going I have some
separations in my own today I'll meet
you at the stone yeah bring your Teddy's
and upping my game you know what I'm
saying you know what I'm saying okay
okay where do I have to get now
and my scale okay I fasters to run that
way running a man and I'm running I'd be
a lot more men and they're not happier
with a belly full of me okay I'm the
brewmaster around here what did you want
a chef what the [ __ ] is wrong with that
guy
[Music]
they run it I'll they run it and here's
a start I'm glad you're here you tellin
like me is the headquarters of the night
we've come to seek the edge we need to
defeat if you'll follow me it's like a
flame away what the [ __ ] and i found
that better for days so this is making a
long I've heard about this place when I
joined again but I never believed it
existed
sumption do anything down and you got a
really clean up your luck did it help
you learn attention from our true nature
what's wrong you can almost hear your
brow furrow try to understand where I'm
no please I'm certainly not allergic why
pick me didn't about religion
yeah they bought fast they're like
what's going on here
you can begin Mia where's the armor
stone I'll activate it I'm not afraid
time's wasting and I should still out
that is showing the road
ok
set from the [ __ ] Batman this is
enough to me
this is enough to make your head spin a
holy [ __ ] she's even hotter I didn't
think this is possible you ready yeah
that this is enough to make your head
spin name yeah okay la Bobby's get up so
now what well then why I appreciate the
honor of becoming a nightingale I would
never
must have nocturnal at our backs to
accept you sir I'm arrangement yeah
Teddy what sort of arrangement I need to
know the terms nocturnal will allow you
to come and write and go in you and your
ability both in life and in bed you must
serve as a guardian twice double hi
there's always a catch but at this point
I suppose there isn't much to lose if it
means the end of mersa fray you can
count me in yeah batch are you ready to
transact the oath with nocturnal yeah
sure bets good time the last effective
you stand on the lightning
come on i don't know we'll see when he
has you okay open the shut-off a waiter
shut all right
okay I'm yeah right now
well what do you want me to go back
should i do you want me to do
I call upon you lady nocturnal queen of
muck and Empress of Shadows hear my
voice lightest of her heart doc Oh
howlive I was wondering when I'd hear
you again lose something did we I've
come before you to turn myself on your
mercy until accept responsibility Oh
ready mind Carla your turn has struck
long ago what could you possibly offer
me
if you pose in life and in death
you surprise me come on this offer is
definitely waited in my favor have some
revenge how interest very well the
conditions are acceptable you may
proceed 90 no exception
we go to kato not aware
very well I name your alicious night in
here and I recycle Anika planet to the
same car life and in the future I
suggest you refrain from disappointing
me again
I cab X
like I love what was that about you
transact theatre it's time to reveal the
final piece of the puzzle to you not as
a true-crime
Master was able to unlock the guild
vault without GPS because of what he
stole from the Twilight Sepulcher the
skeleton key by doing this he's
compromised our side to nocturnal and in
essence well yes all of us possess some
adaptive limiting but once you realize
the cake access these traits but
although it would benefit the guild more
than you can imagine it's a key and
return to its lot as time passed our
luck would diminish to the point of
non-existence and whether you know it on
very true ok let's get it back bring
your [ __ ] business listen live there's
one last piece of business we need to
settle before we go out the Mercer the
leadership of the guilt karliah and I
have thanks to your effort Mercer
stretch as a result we both feel that
you have the pathetic I've been at this
game a long time my friend I'm good at
what I do maybe I've never been one to
leave never desired it never cared for
it don't well we have a bit of an errand
to run before you come then its descent
ill then we have I've been pardoned over
the plans he brought her and I'm
convinced yaad kar liya and I will meet
you there prepare yourself on this will
I permit damaged our review